here we are with Jerry Renner Main
Attraction he's a singer too
here we go with one of the Avengers Main
Attraction by Jeremy Renner
Jeremy Renner looks like a
most regular guy in the world and that's
why people like him because he's so
accessible Jerry Renner Main Attraction
Jeremy Renner is a really good actor
he's actually so good but people don't
realize it because he's got such a
regular face here we go Jeremy Renner
Main Attraction they forgot about it
ever since that [__] movie directed
by that girl
hurt rocker hurt rocker not hurt rocker
because it's not about [__] grandma
it's not about a grandma with [__]
with with plantars fasciitis it's about
a [__] the war so it's not hurt
rocker it's Hurt Locker here we go live
Jeremy Renner Main Attraction here we go
he sings Two For some reason
he's not just an Avenger he's not just a
good dramatic actor he also sings songs
you would listen to in a dentist office
here we go Jeremy Renner Main Attraction
he's getting definitely gonna have songs
about flying and flying so high pretty
soon coming out with the song that's fun
I guarantee you Jeremy Randall have a
song it's called flying too high or
something like that because it would be
in an elevator Jeremy Main Attraction
bullseye
[__] there's a joke in there
somewhere I'm not gonna do it because
he's a Hawkeye Bullseye here we go
Jeremy Renner manufactured
he's got regular faces so good
um
so yeah so uh
but yeah so what the [__] so what was I
even doing saying Jeremy Renner Dude
Killing it man he just made a song he
made some songs
did you know that he dude the fact that
let me just go
let me just start this by saying
I straight up think Jeremy Renner is a
phenomenal actor and I love Jeremy
Renner and I think he's a great [__]
he's he seems like such a good guy he's
a great actor I love him in the movies I
want to [__] be his best friend I'm a
Jeremy Renner fan
and the fact that he's doing also
rock music is
hilarious dude it's awesome his also the
fact that he can just make rock like he
can do any kind of music he can do any
kind of music he can make singer
songwriter [__] he could do stuff that's
really like cool like dark like tool he
could do anything he wants to do
but he chose straight up Rock oh that's
so funny to me dude
with his [__] short hair he just
chose Rock and that's hilarious man
with his reg face dude that makes me
laugh dude and he has a song called Main
Attraction ah
dude Jeremy Renner rips
he's my favorite actor now that he does
rock music did you know that
if he comes to La I'm gonna go do I'm
gonna go to his show as a fan I'm not
asking for any extra perks I'm paying
for the ticket I'm standing in the back
dude it's gonna be so dope I'm not
hitting on my agent sometimes I hit on
my agent could you get tickets for me to
go to nope not this time dude buying
tickets for the Jeremy Renner show
standing in the back and eating popcorn
dude
his song
first of all of course the music video
starts with this [__] the beeps you know
he's walking into a [__] he's got a
long coat
the fact that it starts with oh
dude the fact that it starts like this
[Laughter]
oh and he's walking in the desert
[Music]
dude he's got a long coat
oh [__]
the [__] way it starts
oh dude he's going like this he's
walking down the road he's going like
this I thought today I have to do this I
have to talk about I have to do the
podcast and I can't burn Bridges with
Jeremy Renner
I gotta meet him though bro I I gotta
[__] dude this song rips
if you don't let me tell you something
dude if you don't like this song Main
Attraction you're a [__] hater dude
it's designed to make you feel good
I'm not gonna play the whole thing
because of the little flag it but it's
so dope dude
what is he
you know you know dude
oh and the comment dude not one comment
not about Avengers
oh dude that's the best it's got 4.3
million views
it says this is what Hawkeye did during
those last five years here's another one
what about Thor offworld Doctor Strange
unavailable Captain Marvel don't invoke
her name Hawkeye you wouldn't believe me
if I tell you
every time
Hawkeye you wouldn't believe it if I
tell you
dude just you know what he should
honestly be in the Hawkeye outfit
in this music video Just ripping [__]
fans with the [__]
what do you call it
vroom Brown and it's and then someone
just goes four and they just get ripped
through a [__] thing with a Hawkeye
arrow and and they die and they
literally die and they die Still rocking
out like
they die literally like this with a
[__] with a with a with an arrow like
this and they're just this is how they
die they're doing this and they go like
this they go like this oh dude [__]
German redder oh what the [__] and
they're just like this
that would be the [__] best that
would be the best
I'm sorry but that [__] prowl
look here we go 95 comments Avengers
Hawkeye three percent comments Spanish
two percent comments like the song
that's what this guy tweeted or uh
YouTuber comment okay so let me get this
straight
this is the one I didn't get okay so let
me get this straight he's an actor
singer and makeup artist wow
huh
what about Thor off-world Captain Marvel
unavailable Hawkeye on tour that's what
this guy says
oh man this guy wrote this on camera he
killing it with bow strings off camera
he killing it with guitar strings
definitely a 14 year old guy
well there's some of these are great
though where's the one where the there's
always the comment where that's like how
much yada yada do you wanna rock Jeremy
Renner yes where's that one definitely I
that that's the main YouTube comment I
want to [__] jump off a bridge when I
see it how much do you want to [__]
rock Jeremy Renner yes
or whatever it is I'll I'll find it I
guarantee it's in here
here we go producer how much epicness do
you want in this song Jeremy Renner yes
oh dude you're a dork
dude how much Darkness do you want in
this comment yes
bro that [__] [__] is hilarious no
no what's the [__] I can't believe
this yo the star of the show
yeah wow
you know he had the meeting he was like
I want a rock German this is what Jimmy
writer did when he came into the [__]
thing whatever whatever music [__]
thing he's doing he comes in and he sits
down in that long coat with his [__]
hair how it always is Jim Renner it's so
interesting the only actor never
absolutely ever changes his hair no
matter what part he's doing dude
and he goes and he sits down and he
[__] and they and they and he's his
Universal BMG whatever the [__] it is
you know whatever whatever thing he goes
and he sits down and he walks in hey
what by the way he walks in like that he
walks in like that with his arms out and
he has got the long coat and then he
sits in the chair and they say so Jimmy
Renner we hear you want to do music
we're all for it what kind of music do
you want to make and he goes like he
literally goes like this he says he no
he what he does is there's a toothpick
in his mouth because that's so [__]
badass of course and he goes like this
uh
and he said what's so funny and they say
you asked me what style of music I'd
like to make and the guy says well yeah
why is that funny and he says because
the answer is obvious and then he puts
on sunglasses and then takes them off
and says I want to rock
[Music]
and they go like this yeah we knew it
and then he goes
I'm walking down going down where's the
car man I know valet he does it like
that
and then gives a validated guy two
dollars
[Laughter]
dude he gives a guy he gives a valet
dude generator such a guy who gives
Valley a guy two dollars
and the guy thinks did he make [__]
40 million dollars on Hawkeye and then
he goes like this he goes like this he
literally goes he says hey he goes like
this and he and it's so racist he says
is Eduardo and the guy says oh my God
yes and he says
hey and he gives him two dollars and he
goes don't spend it all in one place
and then drives away
down the road you think he you think but
you can't tell because he doesn't say it
loud enough he says I'm [__] Hawkeye
[Laughter]
oh [__] I'll do a duet with him
I'll do a duet with him you understand
me
oh [__] the God damn Jeremy renders
this [__] dude he gets no hate he's so
good nobody hates him he makes the
killer ass [__] song
and what there's another song too oh he
has another song called Heaven don't
have a name huh
said the name before it didn't have a
name
Heaven don't have a name said heaven in
the title
Chris doesn't have a name
all right no I'm sorry never mind anyway
just uh it's all good just never mind
just
I [__] love it dude
because you're the star of the show man
I'm talking about me secretly
around oh
oh it's always the same hair can't tell
if I'm 35 or 50. brown oh
Thanos loved his voice that's why he was
spared from the snap
14.
someone says I found out he by the way
who found out that Jeremy Renner who
sings because of the Jeep commercial
eh
SE
White
the whitest thing in the world is
finding out Jeremy Renner sings while
watching a Jeep commercial
that's the whitest thing in the world
because all white guys when they saw
that music video they went like this oh
[__]
that's what they did they said oh Jimmy
Runner sings
that's the widest thing the only thing
wider is liking an escape room that's
the only thing whiter
dude if you were in an escape room if
they shut the thing and they were like
if they if you were in an escape room
and they were like hey guys
good luck getting out Clank
we gotta get out we got one minute
another hold on put
nah it's a stupid joke but bro it's just
so [__] awesome that he sings Main
Attraction he's also got a song called
nomad
oh
that's so cool the fact that he could do
any music and he's like hey are you
[__] crazy I Wanna Rock
you know uh [__] generator is the
kind of guy who bites his lower lip when
he [__] because he thinks it's sexy
dude and I do that too so that's all
good me and Jimmy Ritter are [__]
about we're Pals
where Pals were the main attraction
ah [__] I wanna I saw him at the car
wash once and he looked like he was such
a good dad
Iron Man Hey kid we need you for a
distraction Spider-Man okay I'll do it
Hawkeye hold my bow oh god dude these
dorks online
hold my bow
um anyway [__] he killed it Jeremy
Renner props to him he should win the
Grammy Best New Artist
you know what Jeremy Renner does for
sure when he goes to Las Vegas he goes
and he bets
and he he literally sits at the table
and lets the house win for a bunch for a
long time for like I'm talking two two
hours and 15 minutes
he lets the house win and he's losing
money dude I'm talking about parts of
his paycheck okay
and then he says well I guess I guess
today's just not my luck that's not my
day and then he gets up and turns around
and goes to leave
tips the lady a chunk and the lady's
like God damn he's tipping nice
he lost
close to a million dollars and he's
tipping nice
and then he says
after he's turned around he says you
know what
let me just play One More Time
and he [__] catches some chips
plays a bigger bet than he's ever played
more than he lost
and then he gets 13.
and the lady has is showing and showing
a [__] face card
and he and she says you want to hit and
he says you know what the way I've been
playing is so [__] up
I might as well play against the rules
now I'm gonna stay and everyone goes
into German main attractions this singer
did you know some Jeep commercial
and they say you really shouldn't and
Jeremy Renner says I got this
and then she says okay
and then she flips the card over and
it's a six
and then everyone goes and she has to
hit and she flips a card over and it's
another face car and your face card and
Jeremy Renner says hey I'd like that
massage
and then he [__] walks away with his
chips and he comes out of [__] winner
oh
[Music]
and you notice as he's walking into the
elevator nobody noticed until the last
moment that his dick was out the whole
time
bro do you understand that's the [__]
my dream world
not for me to do it I want Jeremy Renner
to do it and I want to see it
I'd [__] start beating the [__] out
of everyone if I saw that out of out of
respect
and I'd be punching this [__] at
everybody and people be like that what
are you doing I'd be like just in case
Jeremy winner doesn't like any of these
guys I got them all
[__] yeah dude that's the life that's
the life in my head